[Musique]
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de rouge parmi
tous ceux qui ont assisté à
l'investiture du nouveau président
brésilien
rouge c'est la couleur du parti des
travailleurs qui a gouverné le pays
pendant 13 ans et que ses partisans ne
veulent plus jamais revoir au palais
présidentiel de l'altiplano jr ball
sonar au succède à michel temer le
vice-président de dilma rousseff qui a
pris le pouvoir après la destitution de
celle-ci par le congrès et
l'emprisonnement du candidat favori l'ex
président ignace you lula da silva deux
présidents totalement improbable celui
ci promet d'imposer la loi et l'ordre de
façon impitoyable
le capitaine de réserve jaillir ball
sonoro avait promis de faire bonne place
à l'armée voici donc son conseil des
ministres très blanc avec seulement deux
femmes mais quatre vrais militaires
notamment à la défense et la sécurité
nationale plus deux autres qui ont fait
carrière dans l'armée et son
vice-président le général à la retraite
hamilton mourant
jr ball sonar ouvertement nostalgiques
de la dictature annonce-t-il un retour
au pouvoir des militaires qui ont
gouverné le brésil par la terreur de
1964 à 1985
vingt ans de détention arbitraire de
torture des centaines de morts et de
disparus en toute impunité
grâce à une loi d'aministie la plupart
des brésiliens sont trop jeunes pour
s'en souvenir
il ya un nouveau élément qui était
vraiment qu'il n'existait pas que ma
génération n'a pas vu
vous voyez que c'est les forces armées
l'armée qui était depuis 80 depuis
canton à 5
absolument retraités ne participez pas
la politique
mais chez les autres il existe bien une
nostalgie de la dictature
je pense que c'est un facteur important
dans l'essence que l' idéologie derrière
ce qu'ils proposent
bon cela l'eau s'est basé sur la
nostalgie de la dictacture les
politiques sont dans la tête des bons
cela a aidé beaucoup de gens qui sont
autour de lui par rapport à au
développement économique de pays
comment affronter les défis sociaux
l' idéologie c'était la même idéologie
pendant les gouvernements militaires
pendant la transition gerbe au sonar ou
à lui-même voulu désamorcer les craintes
respect total de la démocratie et de la
constitution dit-il en démocratie
notamment sa couche de sang il l'a
rappelé dans son discours d'investiture
le grand cheval de bataille du candidat
ben olsen araud a été la corruption qui
sera garanti par son ministre de la
justice le juge sergio moreau le cerveau
de l'opération anticorruption lavage
château qui a fait mettre lula en prison
garant de l'indépendance de la justice à
haut niveau il sera aussi en charge de
la sécurité publique
alors qu'en sera-t-il des droits des
citoyens des femmes des minorités sous
un président ouvertement racistes
misogynes et homophobes
il ne l'est pas en réalité dit le
ministre moreau aussi étrange que cela
puisse paraître c'est à dire ma position
je n'aurais jamais accepté le poste si
j'entrevoyais le moindre risque de
discrimination des minorités coquet
risques ou des discriminations du minho
conscience collective ou de perte
ascanio selena est un chroniqueur
vedette du grand quotidien o globo
il est inquiet minable je suis pas sa
crainte c'est de voir ball sonar aux
mines et les institutions par
l'intérieur
son ministre de l'éducation est un
théologien conservateurs proches de
l'armée
sa ministre de l'agriculture est une
porte parole de la grande agriculture
industrielle celle des exportateurs de
soja de poulet et de boeuf les
écologistes craignent le pire pour
l'amazonie et les territoires indigènes
protéger d'autant plus que le brésil est
en train de se retirer de l'accord de
paris outre la justice le congrès
députés sénateurs pourrait être un
garde-fou contre des tentatives de
démantèlement des lois et des
institutions
c'est pas quelqu'un un outsider total
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît le système
politique brésilien qui connait les
parlements brésilien j'ai peur mais en
même temps je l'espoir qui s'imposent
pas c'est bien en essence qu'en lorraine
gouvernement des droites mais au
gouvernement un cadre et d'institutions
démocratiques
le parti social libéral de bolton arona
que 11 % des sièges au congrès qui
compte 30 partis politiques
il devra tout négocier et donc se
modérer mais il pourra compter sur
l'appui des fameux 3b le boeuf les
balles et la bible les blocs
parlementaires de l'agrobusiness du port
des armes à feu et les évangéliques de
plus en plus puissants et obtint
confiance une confiance
j'ai confiance les institutions sont
solides la cour suprême est une entité
forte
le congrès est une institution forte
avec le congrès on peut tout changer
mais ball sonara aura une opposition
très forte ce ne sera pas facile pour
lui de gouverner mon pauvre sont moins
toutefois sur votre table et les galas
mecs terreur pedro abramova y est plus
pessimiste
c'est une démocratie très très récente
on n'a jamais dans toute l'histoire un
parti a élu qui passe au parti b qui
passe au parti à c'est-à-dire clinton
bosch obama jamais eu dans l'histoire
brésilien vraie alternance de pouvoir
démocratique
on n'a jamais eu donc dire qu'on a des
institutions solides prête pour ce genre
de test alors peut-être qu'on grands là
mais vraiment on n'a pas les éléments
aujourd'hui pour dire ceci 10,4 en si
peu de temps pour tous bouleversés et
les brésiliens seront les juges du bilan
aux élections de 2022